today for our daily cancellation i'm
gonna be performing another exciting fan
favorite the reverse cancellation now
this is usually the move where people
are trying to cancel me but in one
graceful yet
devastating maneuver i spin around and
cancel them instead
today's cancellation will be like that
except it's an even rarer
double reverse cancellation by proxy
what that means in this case
i will be reverse canceling not people
who tried to cancel me
but who tried to cancel someone else
namely rush limbaugh
the canceled mob came for rush limbaugh
yesterday as they have countless times
of course over the past 30 years or
whatever
whatever it is what they were angry
about
this time is that rush limbaugh called
kamala harris
a quote ho and said she was a quote
mattress
for the man she had an affair with years
ago in order to jump start her political
career now
the really interesting point about rush
saying these things is that
he didn't say these things at all in
fact the left claimed that he did but
once again it was fake news rush
merely read some news stories about how
other people
had said this stuff and were facing
backlash uh he didn't even say that he
agreed with it he just read it
so that could be the end of this
cancellation they made up a fake story
about rush
slandered him lied repeatedly etc and so
forth just another monday for our
friends
on the left but this cancellation goes
deeper than that um
let us for a moment leave aside the fact
that rush didn't actually call kamala a
ho
or accuse her of sleeping her way to the
top let us pretend
that he did say those things not because
he was reading a news report but because
those were his own opinions that he was
expressing
and in fact when i first heard about
this controversy i was duped myself
i fell for it i thought he did say it
but i was so busy not
caring about the outrage that i never
checked to see if the outrage was based
on anything that had you know
actually happened and it turns out it
isn't but as i said let's pretend that
it is
or in fact we could just work we can go
with the reworked narrative from the
media once it was revealed that the
first narrative was bunk
they kind of reworked it and now the
headlines like here in the daily beast
it says that russia
russia perhaps didn't call kamala a ho
or say those things about her but he did
quote amplify
quote misogynistic smears he amplified
them
okay well whatever the case
what a strange dichotomy leftists are
claiming to be horribly outraged
horribly offended by the accusation that
a woman slept around
used sex to get ahead was quote a hoe
yet it was less than a week ago that
many of these very same people were
celebrating the empowering feminist
anthem from cardi b that expressly
encourages women to do and be all of
those things
the song begins and ends with a man
shouting the word [ __ ]
and we're meant to see the word in a
positive light in the context of the
song
the women in the song are taking
ownership of it they proudly wear the
label so
what's the problem even if rush did say
it
i thought it was empowering i thought it
was a compliment
sure he wouldn't have said it as a
compliment but who cares if you see it
as a as a as positive if you see a
certain trait as positive and someone
points it out in a negative way why
would you be offended
i personally like being tall so if
someone who doesn't like tall people
came up to me and said you're tall
i wouldn't be offended or upset in the
slightest you know i i
i'm i know how i feel about who i am i'm
happy for you to notice i would say
thank you
the left here wants to reserve the right
to be offended by so-called sexist
smears even while taking ownership of
those smears and claiming that they're
not smears at all
because they're good so they say you
know xyz is good and then a man comes
along and says you're an xyz
the left recoils how dare you this just
doesn't work it doesn't make sense
this is the trick the left tries to pull
all the time though
they want at once to reserve the right
to tell certain people that they can't
say a certain word or make a certain
accusation while at the same time
encouraging the targeted group to live
out the word to be it to embody it to
say it to proclaim it
they do this with men too by the way
they tell men
to reject their masculinity but if you
were to go up to a man
and call him emasculated and effeminate
they would accuse you of a horrendous
slur how so i thought you said it's good
for men to be effeminate
as for women what's worse i ask to call
a woman a [ __ ] as an insult
or to try to convince young women to
actually
be that the first is rude the second is
downright sinister
and certainly far far far more harmful
to society and especially to women
so this really goes back to the old
maxim about how
you can't expect people to respect you
if you don't respect yourself
the feminist approach for years has been
to demand respect for women
from everyone except women themselves
they want everyone else to respect and
recognize a woman's femininity and
dignity
even while working outright to relegate
feminine dignity to the societal ash
heap
but again you can't do this it doesn't
work
either being a quote [ __ ] is bad or
it's not
i say it's bad either women's bodies
should be respected or they shouldn't
i say they should either women should
not be objectified or they should i say
they should not
the left and feminists and pop stars all
want to answer those questions
conditionally intensively tentatively
and change the answer depending on who
is asking
but that's just another way of being a
hypocrite and for that
they are cancelled canceled
cancelled thank you for tuning in to the
daily wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content